a lot of people who would vote Democrat
are bleeding hearts right they believe
that they're trying to help people and
if you're able to say these policies
harm people they are more likely to be
open to them I think the border is the
border is a crazy issue because there
were so many Republicans who like would
not talk about it they were afraid to be
called racist they afraid to do whatever
I mean the Republican house I think or
congress wouldn't necessarily they they
fought giving Trump funding for the
border wall when he was in office
because they're were like well it's not
that big a priority shut down for that
right and look at us now like this is a
major issue we are paying the prices and
in fact we had a president that wanted
to intercede earlier who wanted to stop
this and even if you don't like Trump
right don't you care about human
trafficking don't you care about
Neighbors in your communities dying of
drug overdoses like this is the big
Reckoning at the border which is it was
message messaging around it was like if
you want to close it you're racist